la guerre économique contre la Russie
est condamnable depuis le départ
comme on l'a vu ces dernières années les
sanctions sont une arme à double
tranchant
elles peuvent causer des dommages
comparables si non plus important aux
auteurs et développeurs de ces fonctions
bonsoir Gauthier Gautier Poutine donc
accuse d'Occident on l'a vu d'arrogance
coloniale de vouloir d'ailleurs écraser
son pays avec des sanctions qu'il
qualifient de stupides Gautier
l'Occident et la cause de tous les mots
pour le président russe oui la cause de
tous les mots à travers aussi le la
décadence que représente aux yeux de
Poutine l'Occident c'est d'ailleurs
assez paradoxal parce qu'il reconnaît de
ce fait une effectivité à l'Occident
tout en maintenant qu'il s'agit d'un
ramassis de l'âge et de et de et de
dégénérer ce qui est intéressant dans
les propos de Poutine c'est que au début
de cette allocution donc il a des pains
à la fois les États-Unis et l'Occident
avec des termes que l'on pourrait
exactement retourner pour qualifier la
Russie par exemple il dit les États-Unis
veulent je cite veulent punir ceux qui
ne veulent pas se soumettre
songeons à la Tchétchénie songeons au
géorgien aujourd'hui aux Ukrainiens il a
dit que les États-Unis prétentaient
avoir une mission divine qui est-elle
d'autres qui est-elle présentée d'autres
la mission russe c'est pareil et ainsi à
l'avenant c'est à dire que dans l'esprit
de Poutine finalement ce dont il accuse
les autres c'est aussi finalement son
comportement c'est assez
ce jeu de miroir et donc les occidentaux
les Occidentaux et c'est vrai qu'ils ne
sont pas totalement exemples de
reproches cette fameuse décennie des
années 90 2000 qui a été caractérisée
par quoi par un afflux massif financier
occidentaux en Russie lesquels font
n'ont jamais servi à relever l'économie
russe à faire des investissements
productifs mais sont partis dans les
poches de ceux qui voulaient faire
fortune d'ailleurs entre parmi ces gens
là le l'entourage de Vladimir Poutine
qui à l'époque travaillait avec le maire
de l'ex Léningrad nul doute aussi que
Poutine a dû en croquer de cet argent là
donc effectivement il y a allez disons
il y a humiliation mais vous vous rendez
compte c'est toujours la même affaire
avec l'histoire c'est toujours le même
rapport que Poutine à l'histoire il
congèle l'histoire c'était il y a 30 ans
et il nous ressort encore cette affaire
qui est certain importante mais
qu'a-t-il fait qu'a-t-il fait
entre-temps par exemple pour diversifier
l'industrie russe c'est-à-dire ne pas
être collé et dépendant de la rente des
hydrocarbures qu'a-t-il fait pour
relever le niveau de vie des Russes
c'est quand même invraisemblable qu'un
pays pareil qui regorge de toutes les
richesses continuent et car 140 millions
d'habitants sur 17 millions de
kilomètres carrés continuent pourtant
d'avoir des citoyens russes qui sont
dans la précarité au mieux et dans la
pauvreté pour les autres et puis il y a
une petite disons Elite qui elle gagne
très bien sa vie donc ce dont il accuse
l'Occident il y a des fondements il y a
des choses qui sont vraies et immense
majorité des causes qui sont celles que
la Russie subit c'est lui les a
approfondi et pour le coup Vladimir
Poutine dit en gros les sanctions elles
ne me elles glissent comme l'appui sur
les plumes d'un canard
et il est déterminé bien sûr il l'a dit
Gauthier à poursuivre son opération
spéciale en Ukraine et notamment dans le
bon basse alors d'abord un mot sur cette
appellation suprême spéciale c'est d'un
ridicule achevé tout le monde sait très
bien qu'il y a la guerre le mot guerre
que tous les citoyens russes ne sont pas
cimentés derrière lui comme il le
prétend sinon il n'aurait pas besoin de
procéder à cette espèce de rafistolage
et de de boncarisation du vocabulaire il
y a même une blague qui malheureusement
circule en Russie depuis quelques temps
on dit vous savez le chef-d'oeuvre de
Tolstoï RP désormais s'appellera
opération spéciale épée tout ça est
absurde simplement sur la guerre du don
de basse il maintient et ça c'est une
ambiguïté que l'on a vu depuis que les
troupes se sont retirés de la région de
Kiev il maintient que c'est l'objectif
de la Russie or cet objectif a été revu
à la baisse puisqu’au départ il
s'agissait de des nazifié comme il dit
l'état ukrainien est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'il va se contenter du don de basse ou
est-ce que c'est simplement un retour à
la raison militaire oui il ira jusqu'au
bout mais ce bout là n'est pas celui
qu'il avait prévu donc il y a une
ambiguïté sur cette question d'autant
que il n'hésite pas à agiter le danger
si vous voulez d'un durcissement
occidental qui serait la cause
précisément du sien autrement il dit
arrête qu'on m'arrête arrêtez-vous je
fais un malheur donc c'est toujours dans
la relation avec l'Occident qu'il se
définit parce qu'au fond une vraie
nature russe d'une démocratie il est
incapable d'en définir une